[Music]
welcome to cost 102 which is organizing
your resources for cost management in
GCP hopefully you've all had lunch if
you haven't I apologize for the taunting
donut truck prominently featured in
several slides sorry in advance
there will be no donut truck but
hopefully we'll give you some great
ideas about how to manage your costs on
GCP so as a reminder this session has
Dori our internal QA system linked out
of the next nineteen app on your phones
so if you have questions or you want to
see what other people are asking as we
go please fire up the app click through
and you can both vote up questions and
add your own now today we are here to
answer one important question that I
think is relevant to everyone
using GCP from the tiniest solo
developer to the largest multinational
corporation the question is what is the
best way to structure your resources in
order to understand and managed cost on
GCP now this is not a question that you
can answer once on your first day or
after your first year or five years into
using GCP it's a question I think you
always have to ask yourself on your
journey in our platform and we'll take
that journey together today going from
tiny to large and answer the question
along the way again a reminder for those
who just joined there's a Dory Q&A link
in your app on your phone if you'd like
to ask questions
we'll also leave lots of time at the end
to take questions live so we'll
introduce the concepts we're talking
about a couple of definitions well dive
into a hello world I think no cloud
presentation would be right without a
little hello world for the developers in
the audience
we'll talk about organizations in GCP a
method for structuring your resource
we'll talk about folders and we'll talk
about labels and how those concepts help
influence the design of your
applications and how you can use them to
do reporting and reasoning about costs
we'll also touch on some more advanced
topics and cross link over to a couple
of other sessions that are happening
that dive deeper into customer examples
into the bigquery building export into
using data studio and other more
advanced tools so let's get started
first Who am I I'm James I am a product
manager in Google cloud billing and
cloud billing has a mission inside of
Google's larger mission our mission is
to make billing trustworthy transparent
simple and predictable and each one of
those is quite important especially when
you're living in a world where if you
wanted to you could have a hundred
thousand cores or a whole pile of RAM or
petabytes of storage we really want to
make sure you know exactly what you're
spending why you're spending it and give
you great levers and tools to manage
your workloads and we try to do that at
the lowest possible prices we have a
long history of driving down the cost of
compute on the back of Google's
innovation in infrastructure in our
scale oops
what will you learn we'll look at
projects in the context of organizations
and folders we'll look at labels for
slicing and dicing cost across those
projects and folders and we'll look at
exports and reports that help you track
and trace those costs as you use your
workloads as you run workloads on GCP
we're gonna start as a solo developer
one person one garage one dog I'm told
you have to have all three otherwise
things the chemistry so it's not right
and we'll go all the way up to a
multinational corporation with thousands
of employees around the world and we'll
look at these tools and how they apply
at each step of that that journey in
that growth now quick show of hands how
many here are solo developers dog or not
one person one computer got one in the
back thank you - awesome no dog no dog
in the bag no they wouldn't let you I
know how many of you are in a start-up
small company just getting going about
another quarter folks here small to
medium sized company somewhere in the
middle not a start-up not a huge company
how about a large organization big
multinational about half bringing in the
rest great ok great diversity we will
try to answer these questions for every
one of those types of usage we're gonna
show a couple of best practices along
the way you'll see these slides with a
big bright heading and a best practice
and we'll summarize them all at the end
and of course this whole presentation
both in slide form and in video are
available online afterwards so don't
worry about taking notes a couple of
definitions will talk about
organizations folders projects labels
and billing accounts and I'll dive in
each one of these so you don't have to
speed read below here first an
organization in the context of GCP is
this kind of top-level parent of all of
your folders projects and resources and
it's a way to centrally apply identity
permissions and policies across every
thing in your organization in your own
company or institution and organizations
really give you this level of comfort
you can apply policy once you know it
applies everywhere their trip typically
linked to your company's domain so you
might have a G Suite domain whether or
not you use G suite services that's tied
to that organization and members of that
domain would have a set of permissions
within GCP organizations contain folders
nested up to four levels deep which are
a way to narrow down those permissions
and policies in a way that mirrors the
structure of your company or your teams
we'll talk about that more about that in
a moment once we get below orgs folders
we get down to projects these are the
core building blocks and a place where
workloads live in GCP and they're the
most important for us when we talk about
how billing is structured and reported
in our world everything runs just about
everything runs in the context of a
project and that's the most important
context you'll see when you're looking
at your costs now a project can only
live in one folder so we have to have a
way to crosscut and report across
folders across projects anywhere you
want to see that labeled usage so our
cross-cutting structure is called a
label which is a key value pair a label
key that you define and a value
associated with it that you can attach
to a project or to resources below the
project level we'll look at a bunch of
examples about that in a couple of
minutes finally got to the got to the
Big Green dollar sign a billing account
is this container that pays for usage
within projects and a project is always
paid for by a single billing account in
GCP
once we have those basic structures we
can start to use them to manage the
visibility of our costs seeing what's
happening at each of those levels the
accountability who's causing spend the
control to apply budgets and alerts and
to forecast that's spending and
intelligence to start to reason about
how to reallocate spending how to drive
it down and how to take control of costs
on our platform so this leads us to our
first best practice which is the finest
grain detail you can get about billing
is inside your big query billing export
and this is something you can turn on
for your entire GCP account it's worth
turning it on on day one it will give
you the most my new detail we give you
about everything happening in billing
and we'll look at example queries and
examples of that export in a couple of
minutes all right we're into hello world
this is where we write a C program
that's eight lines long the Prince
Street and I'm kidding this is where we
talk about the basics one project one
small company a startup with their dog
so we have a billing account and a
single project sitting under it within
that project we have some workloads
running and these might be familiar to
you
there's many dozens of services within
GCP but in this project we have compute
engine kubernetes cloud storage bigquery
and cloud sequel all running and they're
all funded by this one billing account
paying for the one project they all
reside in and I've drawn two different
color lines here for a reason
the green dotted line on top is pays for
billing account pays for all of the
usage within a project separately the
project owns the resources contained
within it I drew two color lines because
the permissions on your billing account
and the permissions on your project
our separate you can give a user in your
organization superpowers on their
billing account they can be a billing
account administrator and have full view
of your costs but have no control or
visibility or access to any of those
resources within a project it's a really
important point we'll come back to it
again later but that's why there are
that's why I have this vision test to
see dotted and solid lines we'll get rid
of the detail below just for simplicity
and talk really about billing accounts
and projects so you were one developer
with your dog in a bag and you've now
hired two more you hired Bob and Alice
Bob and Alice are great you hired two
great developers you got lucky you found
really good ones that Alice is a really
good coder alice is not super up on
Linux systems administration so she ran
RM dash RF thinking she was in her home
directory she wasn't she was at the root
she's wondering why that's taking so
long at the same time Bob here Bob is
JavaScript like you can't believe but
Bob and sequel don't really get along
very well
he wrote a update query without a where
clause he's wondering why that's taking
a long time you're wondering maybe about
whether you hired the greatest Bob and
Alice you could have hired but they're
gonna be okay their faces turned to
frowns as they realized they've done
something awful in production and now we
have our first split we need a second
project we need to develop an
environment because Bob and Alice need
to get some guardrails on what they're
doing both projects are funded by the
same single billing account but now we
can divide permissions between them we
can look at the cost of our production
environment it might be many times the
size of our dev environment and we can
put them in some silos so they don't
blow away prod again this leads us to a
another best practice use projects to
enforce boundaries between workloads
between teams or when you really need to
know about the cost of one set of usage
completely partitioned from another a
great way to enforce policy now probably
many of you have multiple projects
already in GCP so let's move on let's
look at how you actually see the cost of
these projects and then
add some more complexity as we grow our
company well the first way you're gonna
see these costs is with your invoice at
the end of the month in your invoice
tells you your company its address how
much you owe Google and some degree of
break down about those costs on a
project and resource level the invoice
is great for one thing it's great for
telling you how much you owe but it's
not really a great cost report
you can't slice it and dice it there is
both a PDF and a CSV and you can slice
and dice the CSV a little bit but we'll
look at a much better way to do those
kinds of questions rather than firing up
a spreadsheet and going and querying it
that way second tool billing reports now
we're getting to an interactive way to
slice and dice cost and we'll look at
some real examples slice and diced by
project by organization by label in a
few minutes
finally the bigquery building export I
mentioned this at the beginning this
first best practice really easy to turn
it on and we'll look at some real data
in a few minutes about what you can get
out of it to turn on your bigquery
export go to your billing account click
on the billing export link and you'll be
able to turn on that export and put it
into a project so another best practice
use the billing reports and exports to
answer the why questions use your
invoice to reason about what you owe
Google that kind of bottom line by the
way if your invoice ever grows beyond 25
pages in a PDF will start to collapse it
down so we don't send you the world's
largest PDF to try and open then you're
poor poor web browser the CSV version of
the of the invoice is full detail always
as big as it gets
so our startup is growing Bob and Alice
now have dozens of teammates and we're
gonna put an organization to help manage
policy and control all of these projects
in our world now probably a best
practice to do from the start but this
startup didn't know that so there
they're evolving as they go so we've
grown we have a whole range of projects
we decided we wanted to put a staging
environment in the middle of dev and
prod we have our macro service that old
legacy big old pile of code somewhere
that chugging away the founder made a
project called top secret don't look
there there's an archive for old stuff
but yeh we're growing turns into help
we're growing when you start to get
beyond the tens of projects it gets hard
to reason about the world gets hard to
partition policies permissions and
control so what can we do here well
first we're working on a feature which
hasn't yet launched but will start to
roll out to customers later this year to
have one default billing account for the
entire organization and when that's live
you won't have to reason about billing
accounts and a per project basis you can
set it and forget it at the organization
level so that's something that's coming
once we get into this multi-project
world the same tools still apply but you
start to have a need to filter and slice
and dice to understand costs below the
organization level using some of the
structural concepts we talked about
earlier so this is a real billing report
and this shows a number of projects all
grouped together there's a couple of
other sessions that go deep into this
tool but I'll give you the highlights
here today billing reports let you drill
into cost by the mechanisms I just
described and here we have them broken
by project so I've opened up this filter
to let me see by project I can tick
those off and change how I group and
show cost over time to see what's
growing and what's shrinking and
obviously sometime mid-march we ramped
up a lot of usage and we see that across
all those projects I can do a similar
kind of reporting using any of the data
that we have in my bigquery billing
export for those fans of sequel among us
this is the 13 lines of sequel that
generated a report by grouped by the
project which is the project ID in this
column under ID the bigquery billing
export is giving you very fine-grained
detail on your usage so you'll have one
row for each couple of hours of usage by
service by application by project by
label and you can query it as you like
you can also press that magical Explorer
and data studio link and go out into a
world of visualization and reporting
tools that work incredibly well with
bigquery there are a couple of other
sessions that go deep with actual
customer examples of that we'll talk
about that and at the end and I'll let
you know about those sessions
the invoice also ships a CSV which I
mentioned a couple minutes ago for
completeness this is what it looks like
you'll see billing account project a
billing account ID project name what
product you're running the resource type
networking vs compute IDs dates amounts
of usage the kind of fields you would
expect but not at the level of
granularity of our bigquery export so
the takeaway from this section from a
control and policy perspective
organizations are for everyone they're a
great thing to turn on whether or not
you use gee suite and all of the other
apps that sit alongside in a domain
anyone can turn on an org and its
associated identity as a service for
free and that's a great best practice
now we ended our organization part being
in a little bit of trouble we had a lot
of projects and the world was only
growing and you can start to see the
delineations where these projects are
really in buckets first column is stages
or environments of our application the
second column is our macro service or
old legacy stuff that we broke out we've
got some acquisitions now top secrets
still there
don't mention it archive we can put in a
layer of folders to start to control who
can see each of those resources and
start to manage the cost and be able to
report on costs by folder and there are
different ways to structure it in one
form you can structure it by environment
if that suits you in another form you
can structure it by the logical
application you could structure it by
team by department by country you're
going to align these folders to how you
work and the structure that makes the
most sense for you and you can have a
lot of them they nest you can have as
many folders as you need to contain your
projects by the way you can have
thousands of projects no problem
platform scales up to many many many
thousands we have customers with one we
have customers with tens of thousands
so folders mirror how you work but
they're not the only way to structure
resources not the only way to bucket
them and you can think of them a little
bit like a primary key a project can
only be in one folder but we need
something else to answer questions like
how much did I spend on databases across
this entire set of applications and
tools tough to answer my folder because
I have databases kind of all over the
place let's just take the app folder and
expand that out and see how many things
are actually a database here well I've
got some my sequel servers running on
bare metal GCE so to speak I've
installed them myself they don't run in
cloud sequel those are databases so
let's label those instances with a key
in value the key is type value is
database now I can do some cross-cutting
reporting within this folder and across
these projects to see how much I spent
across my databases turns out I got
databases in a lot of other places let's
say I added a bunch of Postgres down in
cloud sequel and I have backups in
production really big ones and I want to
attribute those costs to my databases
that they're backups of I don't want to
confuse them with other data that's
running in my environment so labels on
compute engine labels and cloud sequel
labels and cloud storage and now I can
report across them to roll up cost as I
mentioned there are trade-offs here you
can think of a folder a little bit like
a primary key each project has can live
Olien in one folder they can be nested
but it can only have one parent and you
can think of labels is like a set of
secondary indexes on your resources and
on your projects it's worth being
deliberate in this design in both cases
it's worth being really deliberate in
your folder design because while it's
easy to move projects around it might be
disruptive for policy and permissions to
be shuffling folders all the time in
labels it's worth thinking about
governance
about the keys that you require and the
values they contain so that Alice
doesn't say type : d be on a label and
Bob says type : database and all of a
sudden we're living in two different
reporting worlds so be deliberate some
resources will are sorry some workloads
will automatically annotate their
resources with labels for you so if you
use deployment manager and certain other
services will Auto tag resources and you
can piggyback on those to do reporting
automatically in cross-cutting so what
does the world look like if we want to
cross cut by label in these two
reporting contexts first in my reporting
view I can both filter and group by
label and here I've done it with my
environment label and I've got
production tests and dev that cross cut
across all my projects I've there 18
projects that are rolled up in this view
and this is the usage of those labels
spanning all of those projects if I drop
into bigquery I can take just about the
same 13 lines of sequel we saw before
and I added a little bit more
it's a nested field so we added a couple
of lines to both unnecessary have labels
key is ends now we've cross cut that
high-resolution billing data by label
and we've got a per month per service
cost for each of those resources running
across our entire environment and of
course that magic button is still there
exploring data studio if you want to
slice and dice and visualize labels are
like supercharging your reporting the
way we think about them as a best
practice is they shouldn't be the
end-all be-all of your reporting don't
rely exclusively on labels start with an
org put projects and folders use a
sensible project layout but then when
you want a supercharged
add on this layer and you can really
dive deep into cost so it's a fantastic
way to help with those gnarly
cross-cutting cases couple of advanced
topics then we'll leave a good bit of
time for questions first as I mentioned
the beginning billing I am billing
Identity and Access Management and
resource I am the roles and permissions
on billing accounts and projects are
completely separate you can give your
finance team billing account admin
permissions there'll be a super user
they can run their queries in bigquery
they can look at billing reports they
can do absolutely everything you can do
on a billing account but they will not
be able to go and actually use resources
see resources change settings and
projects because those worlds are split
that's a very intentional choice there
are other roles on billing accounts that
offer fewer permissions the ability to
create them and view them but not to
have that level of administrative
control there are a couple of best
practices once you start to think about
this kind of larger organization billing
one of them is parent your billing
accounts in your organization just like
projects it's not required but it's a
good practice to do so you get that
central control over the roles on your
billing accounts to put all your
projects in your organization especially
if you're in transition and remove the
billing account creator role from your
org for the vast majority of customers
one billing account is the only billing
account you'll ever need a billing
account corresponds to a single invoice
in a single currency and most customers
are fine with one some very large
customers or customers with special
needs will have multiple billing
accounts they might operate in multiple
currencies they might have a complex
jurisdictional situation or departments
that really want their own separate
invoice and in that case they'll stray
and have multiple invoices multiple
billing accounts but one is typically
good enough
once you take that creator role away
anyone creating a project will always
land that project in the org and it will
always be funded by your orgs single
billing account so you're from a
governance perspective you're covered
as I mentioned fewer are better and a
couple of advanced scenarios why you
might stray into having multiple billing
accounts and I'm happy to answer
questions about that if if you have
questions about whether that's right for
you and right for your company there's a
session which I'll show on a slide later
on the schedule cost 200 which talks
about a level above kind of in the
Google world above cloud and how your
organization and its domain relate to
some other things outside the Google
cloud world you might have an adze
account you might be paying for G suite
there's a separate payments profile that
lives above cloud that spans all of
those products and if you're an
administrator of an organization
especially a large organization or have
a controller ship or governance kind of
concern this is probably an interesting
session for you and I'll show you where
that is in the schedule in a moment last
best practice everyone in cloud every
customer from the smallest to the
largest get free cloud billing support
we have a wonderful support team that is
here to help with billing questions we
recognize that billing can be stressful
and it's really really important that we
answer your questions
solve the concerns and problems you have
so please always feel free to reach out
there are links throughout the cloud
console that lets you click through and
get a question answered by our dedicated
billing team you can grant that billing
team access to your bigquery billing
export and they will be very thankful if
you do that if you have a really gnarly
question because they'll be able to go
look at that same super high granularity
billing data that you see and help
reason about questions and concerns
so in summary enable bigquery building
export on day one it's almost zero cost
we give you ten gigs of bigquery for
free it's two cents a gig after that
you're gonna be a pretty large customer
before you have gigs of billing export
data that'll be the last cost you notice
so turn that on on day one use projects
to enforce the boundaries between teams
or workloads or sensitive contexts
within your applications and those will
be reflected in your billing data at
that project level when you're trying to
answer why go first to cost reporting
tools and second to your invoice the
invoice is how much you owe cost
reporting lets you do that slicing and
dicing organizations are for everyone
identity as a service is free we
encourage you to use it associate it
with your domain and get that level of
policy and control the top level from
day one use folders to mirror how you
work a project can only live in one so
think about that as kind of the primary
key and then supercharge your reporting
by adding labels that cross cut across
resources and across projects to get
that extra level of detail and finally
cloud billing support is here to help
please reach out they'd love to field
your questions and help with billing
concerns there are four other sessions
that I'll point out there are twelve
cost management sessions happening it
next but there are four that I think are
particularly interesting for this
audience is kind of a deeper dive into
these tools and into real customer data
cost 202 which is better insight
measuring the cost of an application on
GCP is target we'll be diving in with
some other billing product managers
that's today at 220 cost 200 is going up
a level and looking at how your
organization and your billing accounts
to relate in the bigger picture how to
think about governance and control
cost 201 on Wednesday afternoon is a
financial governance session looking at
budgets and alerts a feature we haven't
really talked about but there's a full
set of budgeting and API budgeting api's
and alert api's that lets you set
thresholds in your projects and finally
on Thursday another customer deep dive
beyond your bill getting more detail
into costs look at more detail in an
actual customer example of bigquery data
studio and how to slice and dice with
real data these are all linked off of
cloud google.com slash cost - management
as well and these slides will be
available for your review later on all
right that's the end of our time thank
you very much for joining us enjoy the
rest of next
[Applause]
[Music]